Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Dr. Camille Reagan, and I'm from the Cancer Prevention Control
program at Fox Chase Cancer Center, Temple Health in Philadelphia.
And I hope everyone's enjoying an outstanding meeting so far.
Right?
So it's my honor to serve as the chair of this year's
selection committee for the AACR Minorities in Cancer Research,
Jane Cooke Wright Lectureship.
Before we begin, I'd like to invite Dr.
Badu,
our senior medical science liaison at Gilead and Kite
Oncology, to offer a few remarks. Dr.
Badu.
Okay.
Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
It's an honor and a privilege to be here on behalf of
Gilead Sciences and Kite Oncology, representing the
AACR Jane Cooke Wright Lectureship.
This moment not only celebrates the powerful legacy of Dr.
Jane Cooke Wright and her meritorious contributions to the field
of cancer research, but also her commitment to the advancement
of minority investigators in cancer research.
As a pioneering cancer researcher and surgeon who also
co-founded the American Society of Clinical Oncology and was the first
woman president of the New York Cancer Society, Dr.
Wright opened the world of evidence-based chemotherapy and
showed how effective it was in helping to treat cancers, which
has become the cornerstone of modern oncology.
Her legacy reminds us today that not only does representation
matter, but also standing up to overcome barriers and
champion progress in science for the sake of patients.
At Gilead, we are committed to investing in the science of oncology,
virology, and inflammation, which translates into delivering
transformative therapies while advancing health equity.
Our support of this lectureship is a testament to the commitment we
have in fostering collaboration, innovation, and
investing in a future where all voices are empowered to
shape the direction of cancer care.
As a PharmD by training and a board-certified oncology pharmacist, I
understand the necessity and impact of the work we do for those
affected by cancer. It is inspiring to be a part of a mission
that strives to improve outcomes for all people, including those
underrepresented.
This award is a reminder of what's attainable when we champion both
excellence and inclusion in cancer research. Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Badu. On behalf of the officers and
directors of the AACR board, I'd like to thank you and
your colleagues at Gilead and Kite Oncology for your ongoing
collaboration and partnership, and this has allowed the
AACR the great opportunity and privilege to administer this
prestigious scientific achievement
award.
The AACR established this lectureship in 2006 to
recognize outstanding scientists who have made
meritorious contributions to the field of cancer research
and who have, through leadership or by example, furthered the
advancement of minority investigators in our field.
It's my great honor to recognize this year's recipient,
a visionary whose impact on cancer research is felt
worldwide.
Dr. Ahmed Jamal has transformed the field
of cancer epidemiology through pioneering integrated
analyses of population-based cancer surveillance
systems. His work has deepened our understanding of
cancer incidence, mortality, and
disparities. Dr. Jamal serves as the Senior
Vice President of Surveillance, Prevention, and Health Services Research
at the American Cancer Society in Atlanta, Georgia.
And he not only is an extraordinary public health
leader and cancer researcher, but also a dedicated
mentor who has guided and inspired investigators
across the United States and around the world.
His career has shaped the way we understand the patterns and
determinants of cancer, rooted in deep commitment
to health equity. Dr. Jamal's work highlights
how access to care influences outcomes across communities,
particularly in rural populations. And Dr.
Jamal began his academic journey
at the Addis Ababa University in Ethiopia and
later earned his PhD in epidemiology from Louisiana State
University. His career in cancer research took shape
during a fellowship in cancer epidemiology at the National Cancer
Institute in the Department of Cancer Epidemiology and Genetics.
Since joining American Cancer Society in 2001,
Dr. Jamal has been a driving force behind
groundbreaking research that tracks incidence, cancer
incidence, mortality, survival, and disparities both nationally and
globally.
His work on disparities, social determinants of health, and
the real-world impact of public health policy has not only
informed cancer control strategy, but has also
sparked new directions in etiologic
research. With more than 500 original
publications and an extraordinary
H-index of 169Dr. Jemal
is among the most influential voices in oncology.
His leadership on the annual US Cancer Statistics
Report, one of the most widely cited publications
in our field, and his co-authorship of two of the most cited
global cancer statistics papers of the century
further underscores his immense scientific legacy.
Dr. Jemal has redefined what cancer surveillance
science can be.
His vision and scholarship have laid the foundation for
new approaches that continue to guide research,
policy, and practices around the world.
It is my great pleasure to introduce the recipient of the
AACR's Minority in Cancer Research Jane Koch-Wright
Lectureship to Dr. Ahmedin Jemal.
Thank you.
Thank
you.
I'm not used to it. Not only used, probably first time in my
life, so it's
funny.
Yeah.
First of all, thank you, Dr. Regan, for your kind
words. And
I'm
truly humbled by this award, and
I'm grateful to AACR and to the
selection
committee, and also
the
Glide and Kite Oncology for
sponsoring this award. So before I
start talking about use of surveillance data to promote cancer
prevention and control at American Cancer Society
through our
facts and figures in the cancer statistics article as well as
research papers, I would like to thank a few people who
got me here.
First, really all started with great mentors.
I've been fortunate enough to be mentored
by Dr. Susan DeFeizer at
NCI during my postdoc. Really, she took a chance on
me, to be honest, because I didn't have any cancer background in
epidemiology. I came from a vet school,
not even classical epidemiology.
My actual PhD work was
only in adult formation in catfish.
But
I did
a
classical
epidemiology when I was in Ethiopia looking
at the impact of tsetse fly control on health and productivity of
cattle, which I used for my master's and got two
papers out of it. That really motivated me to be
more of a cancer control person and an
epidemiologist. Second, I would like to thank Dr.
Michael Thun. He was really
an outstanding epidemiologist, a great
writer. What I have learned about writing
big picture papers, it is from
Michael Thun. Actually,
I think my second or third year, Michael
Thun, he said,
"Ahmedin." I say, "Yes?" "You always hit single, not
home run." I couldn't understand what it mean.
So I looked, "Michael, what do you mean?" He chuckled and
said, "You don't publish in
high impact journal. You publish just in small journals."
So I took that
as a challenge, to be honest, and he made me really
a better epidemiologist. But anyway,
coming back to
what already I said,
I would also like to thank Dr. Bill
Dahut for his trust
in what I and my team do, as well as
other
colleagues there. They can testify we are free what we
want to do. That is really a freedom that we
got from Bill. And I also would like
to thank my incredible talented
teammates. It's just that not only hard
worker, they are really, really passionate to what they do.
So this award is as much as theirs as mine.
Okay. And finally, I would like to thank my family,
my wife, Hawa Adam, who is
in Ethiopia. I have my two kids,
Nadia and Zakir, who are both in med
school, and my brother, Abdu, and
his wife, Fadila, for their really patience
and also for emotional support.
Now,
I have no disclosures to make. And
so I will start with our cancer facts and figures.
We regularly publish nine facts and figures in
the statistics article on a regular basis.
And cancer facts and figures, what we call the
blue book,
is our principal publication that we have been publishing it
every year since
1951. And
thisPublications are widely
used by the cancer community, including ACS staff and
volunteers, cancer control advocates, researchers
here,
many of you, and policymakers. And the "Cancer Stats"
article is one of the most
cited article in the
cancer literature, and also it
receives extensive media coverage.
So
for example, this year's "Cancer Stats" article that we
published in
January was covered in major media
outlets including Washington Post, USA Today,
the CBS Nightly News, and the Good Morning
America, Dr. Bill DeHaath discussing the main findings
of the paper,
specifically a new milestone in five-year
survival rate of
70% with the Good Morning America
co-host.
So, ACS is really unique
among nonprofit non-research organizations
because we have a research
arm that includes both intramural and extramural
research program. We have a cancer
patient support or a cancer control program.
We have also a 501advocacy
arm called American Society Cancer Action Network
that lobbies regulators, policymakers for
rules
on the regulation that advances cancer research,
cancer prevention, and control. So we in the
Surveillance and Prevention Health Services Research team
work closely with the staff in patient support,
ACS CAN, and other departments in the
discovery pillar
to identify and fill research gaps
for evidence-based decision-making.
So I'm going to provide example of our studies that
have driven
or informed etiological studies,
guidelines, and health policies in three broad
research topics: emerging cancer trends in young adults,
geographic patterns of cancer, and access to care.
The late
Sir Richard Doll, he's really an eminent physician
epidemiologist in UK, suggests that emerging cancer
trends in young adults
reflect recent changes in cancer risk factors.
And they do also foreshadow future disease burden as
these young adults with either
elevated or reduced risk carry their risk forward
to older age group.
And we know that lung cancer incidence
historically has been higher in
men than in women because men smoked at a higher
rate. But this figure
is from a paper that we published in
International Journal of Cancer in 2003
and shows age-specific lung cancer incidence under
age 55
by birth cohort from those born in
1925, the greatest generation, to
those born in 1970, the X generation.
And data for men is shown in the blue line and for
women in red line. So incidence
rates continued to decrease in successive
generation in both men and women,
except in those under age
40 in women, rates began to increase
beginning
those born in 1950s, leading to a convergence
of rates between men and women born since in
1960.
This
increase in incidence rate
in women coincided with
an increase in initiation of smoking in
girls in late 1960s and in
1970s because of
deceptive tobacco marketing
targeting young women.
In 1968, Philip Morris
introduced Virginia Slims cigarettes and marketed
under a slogan of, "You've come a long way, baby."
And the picture at... Oops, sorry.
The picture at the top of
the cigarette package
shows a woman hanging
laundry. And next,
the small font that you see under the picture is,
"Back then every man gave his wife at least one
day a week out of the house." And followed
by, "You have come a long way, baby." And ends
with, "Virginia Slims. Slimmer than a cigarette
men smoke." Really, this kind of deceptive
advertisement
led to an increased initiation of smoking in those
during 1960s and '70s, which means those who
were born in
1950s.And
15 years later, after we published the convergence of lung
cancer incidence
in men and women in young adults, we
updated the analysis using nationwide population incidence and
smoking data and found out that
lung cancer incidence rate is now higher in young women
than young men under age
50.
And you can specifically, incidence rates
in women crossed over those in men
born since 1960, and this was very
statistically significant, reversing the historically
high lung cancer incidence in men than in women.
And this difference
in the
higher lung cancer rate in women than in men in those born in 1960
is not really fully explained by differences in smoking
prevalence.
This figure shows current smoking prevalence
by age, sex, and birth cohort.
Smoking prevalence between men and women converged
in those men and women born since 1960.
But smoking prevalence in women did not
exceed those in men to explain the higher lung
cancer incidence in women than in men, except
for this small
higher
rate in age 40 to 49, which
going back, those born in 1950s.
And also the intensity of smoking, as we measured
by average number of cigarettes smoked per day, was
substantially lower in women than in men
at each age and birth cohort. And that cannot explain the higher
lung cancer incidence in women.
And also other
risk factors, use of tobacco products like
smokeless tobacco use, cigar use is much lower in women
than in men. Also,
historical occupational exposures such as
asbestos and arsenic. And there was no also
difference in second-hand smoke between men and women.
So we extended the analysis to 40
countries. So the higher lung cancer incidence rates in
women than in men under age
50 was not confined to the US. We also found a
similar pattern in Canada, parts of
Europe, and in New Zealand. And these
patterns were not explained again by differences
in smoking prevalence. So collectively, our
finding on higher lung cancer incidence in women than in men
under age 50 renewed interest in
understanding sex difference in lung cancer
risk, specifically whether women are genetically more
susceptible to tobacco carcinogen,
or whether the background rate, which
is the lung cancer rate among never smokers, is
higher in women than in men.
We also published quite a few articles on rising
trends in young onset cancer,
specifically for colorectal cancer and also
for other common cancer. But the
most influential paper
is the one led by Rebecca Siegel, where
we looked at
colorectal cancer incidence by age
period and birth cohort.
This figure shows age-specific trends in
colon cancer by
10-year age interval before age 50, and by
five-year age interval after age
50. And during the most recent time period, incidence
rate increased
under age 55 and continued to decrease
in age 55 and older. Similarly,
for colon cancer, incidence increased
during the most recent time period in those age under 55
and decreased in age 55 and older.
But what is interesting is when you look at the year in
which incidence began to increase, there is a 7 to
10 years lag between two consecutive age group.
For example, for colon cancer, incidence
began to increase
early in 1980 in age 20 to 29.
In late 1980s in age 30 to 39,
and in late 1990 in 40 to
49. So as those young adults with elevated
risk carrying their risk into older age
group, which this is a very classical birth cohort effect, that is,
those men and women born in a specific
period have a higher risk
of exposure. In this case, those born in
1950s and '60s.
This figure show the incidence rate ratio by birth
cohort from those born in
1980,
'90the lost
generation and to those born in
1990,
millennials, using the 1992 cohort
as a reference.
And the data for colon is shown in blue,
for rectum is shown in orange. The risk of
both colon and rectum cancer
continued to decrease
since those born 1980, 1990. But
then
the risk increases for both colon and
rectum since
those born in 1950.
Compared to baby boomers, those born in 1950,
millennials, or those born in 1990,
had a fourfold risk of rectal cancer and
a twofold risk of colon cancer.
And this finding served as a
catalyst for SEER in 2018
for US Preventive Services Task Force in
2021 to lower the age
for initiating colorectal cancer
screening from 50 years to 45 years.
And our findings on early onset
cancer, in addition to findings from other
groups, served as a foundation for
large-scale etiologic studies to
understand the underlying risk factors for this
increase. And this includes the NCI
provocative questions
in 2020, which says, "What
are the underlying cause of unexplained rising
incidence in certain early onset cancer?" And there is also
a more recent 25 million or 20 million
cancer grant challenge in
2023 to understand
the underlying risk factor for
early onset cancer.
And this lowering the age for
initiation of
screening from
50 to 45 years has already led to a positive
outcome. Both colorectal cancer screening and local
stage diagnosis increased sharply in
age 45 to 49, following the
recommendation, potentially averting hundreds, if not
thousands, of
deaths from colorectal cancer.
Apologies. Okay. So I'm going to provide as an
example, one paper on geographic patterns of cancer.
So this is a paper that we published in 2015,
led again by my colleague, Rebecca Siegel,
where we found three cluster of counties with
high colorectal cancer mortality, with rates
40% higher in Lower Mississippi Corridor than
the rest of the United States. And these areas were
characterized by high poverty, low
colorectal cancer screening, as well as high prevalence of
smoking and obesity, a known risk factor for
colorectal cancer.
And this finding served as a catalyst for community
actions to expand colorectal cancer screening services
in many Southern states, including the
Carolina Screening Initiative, which was
established in 2016, less than one
year after we published the paper.
Also, the American Cancer Society, Cancer Action
Network staff and volunteers have used this data
to persuade lawmakers from Southern states to
co-sponsor and pass Removing Barriers to Colorectal
Cancer Screening Act of 2020,
which eliminated cost-sharing, or commonly
known as a surprise bill, for colonoscopy
after
fecal
occult blood test or positive blood test.
And
this is mainly actually in Medicaid enrollee.
Finally, I'm going to provide a few of our example
on access to care.
Not a surprise, the United States continue to be the only
very high-income country without universal health
coverage.
Before the implementation of the Affordable Care Act in
2007, there were about 47 million
individuals under age 65 who are uninsured,
representing about 18% of the population.
And healthcare reform was a major
issue during the 2018 presidential
campaign.
President
Barack Obama embraced a larger government
role to expand access to care, while the
late Senator John McCain favored free market.
And during the heat of this campaign, we
published a paper led by myBy
Dr. Elizabeth Ward, who was
my boss at that time,
showing a striking survival disparity between
privately insured,
uninsured, or Medicaid-insured patients for colorectal
cancer.
Specifically, survival for uninsured or
Medicaid-insured
patients diagnosed with stage one disease had
poorer survival than
privately insured patients diagnosed with stage
two disease. So this finding was used by
ACS CAN and other
civic societies to advocate for the passage of
the Affordable Care Act, which was signed into law
in March 2010.
So the
Affordable
Care Act has several provisions. The early
provision of the law that were implemented in 2010 and
2011 were dependent coverage expansion that
allowed young
adults to be covered under their
parents' insurance until they turn 26,
and elimination of cost-sharing for preventive services
approved by the US Preventive or recommended
by the US Preventive Services Task Force.
But the major provision of the law
were implemented in 2014,
including Medicaid expansion that
expanded Medicaid to broader group of
low-income adults for
income up to 138 federal poverty
level. And by January
2014, 24 states and the
District of Columbia expanded Medicaid, shaded
in blue.
And the second major provision was establishment of health
insurance marketplace, which
offered subsidized insurance to
adults with family income of up to
400% federal poverty level.
And our group has published quite a few articles
on the positive effects of the Affordable Care Act.
But in the interest of time, I'll just provide you
one example related to the dependent coverage
expansion and
maybe a couple of examples related to Medicaid expansion.
So as
example of dependent coverage
expansion, we examine changes in
proportion of early-stage disease and receipt of
fertility-sparing treatment for cervical cancer
in age 21 to 25, and in those
26 to
34 who are eligible for the provision,
and
26 to 34 who are not eligible.
And following the implementation of this
provision, both proportion of
early-stage cancer and receipt of fertility-sparing treatment
sharply increased in age 21 to 25,
shown in the blue line, who are
dependent coverage eligible, but not in
those 26 to 34.
And this finding was the first to
make an association between the Affordable Care Act and cancer
outcomes and was really covered by major media
outlets, including "The New York Times."
As an example of effect of Medicaid expansion, we looked at change
in uninsured rate and stage at diagnosis before and
after the implementation of the Affordable Care Act in Medicaid
expansion state versus in the non-expansion states.
And this figure shows
changes in uninsured
rates in expansion state, shown in blue, and in
non-expansion state, shown in orange.
You can see that following the
implementation of Medicaid expansion,
as well as also marketplace exchange occurred that same time,
uninsured rate declined in both
groups, but the decline in uninsured rate was
greater in the Medicaid expansion state, the blue
line.
But then we looked at where is this coming from, where this
reduction in uninsured rate. Then we looked at by
insurance type. The increase in
uninsured rate in the expansion state is because of an increase in
Medicaid expansion.
But in the non-expansion state, the decline in uninsured rate is
because of an increase in private insurance.
So this is important. So
what it's showing is that both Medicaid expansion
and subsidized insurance are effective in expanding
access to care. Unfortunately, the current
administration didn't renew their
subsidies and leading to over maybe
20 million people, either uninsured or face
incur higher cost.
We looked at also the uninsured rate by Medicaid
expansion and then expansion state by area-level
socioeconomic status. So you can see that in
the-Non-expansion states,
almost the disparity in uninsured rate
by socioeconomic status eliminated, but
not in the non-expansion state.
Also, the disparity in uninsured by race/ethnicity
substantially diminished in the expansion state, but
not in non-expansion state.
We also saw a small shift towards early state diagnosis
in Medicaid expansion states
for cancer that can be detected early through
screening and clinical symptoms,
specifically for colon, female breast, and
melanoma.
And last December, we also looked at
changes in five-year survival rates
by Medicaid expansion. And
we found that the net gain or the improvement in
five-year overall survival in expansion state
compared to non-expansion state was
significant in rural areas where you have the high poverty,
the higher uninsured rate. And in those areas
where there is high poverty, not so much in low
poverty. That's exactly what the law was
designed to address.
We also found an increase in non-Hispanic
whites and non-Hispanic Blacks because poverty cannot
discriminate,
I guess.
But this
paper was accompanied by Dr.
Electra Paskett and
titled "Universal Access to Healthcare, Time to
Realize the Experiment Was a Success."
And our findings were
used in
amicus
brief in support of the Affordable Care Act in federal
courts, including the Supreme Court.
I will summarize that I think
I've demonstrated to you the value of surveillance
data, surveillance in health service research to
promote cancer prevention and control, and
the need to increase investment in population-based cancer
registries, as well as population-based surveys.
And I also maybe
underscore the importance of strong collaborations between researchers,
cancer control departments, advocacy organizations,
and lawmakers to translate research
findings to action.
And again, I would like to
acknowledge the contribution of my teammates,
my internal, external collaborators.
Very difficult to list them on one slide,
including many of you here, Alpa here, my colleague and
friend. And the cancer registrars who are
tirelessly and diligently
collecting the information from medical records.
And the NCI, CDC, the North American Association of Cancer
Registry, the American College of Surgeons, for
curating the data and for making it available
for us researchers. And yeah, thank you
for your attention.
I hope
I tried to address what I can do.
Dr. Jamal, can we ask you a question, please, sir?
You are not done yet. You are not done yet.
No, sir. No. We've got to ask questions.
Understood. But come on now.
Come on now. You don't have to be a public speaker.
Did a fantastic job.
So first of all, I'm Karen Wingfield.
I'm a radiation oncologist at Vanderbilt-Ingram Cancer Center and Associate
Director of our Community Outreach and Engagement there.
I just want to thank you so much for your work.
I will say, I am completely blown away by just the sheer volume,
and I bet you every single person in this room who has done anything related to
population health or anything related to disparities has cited your work.
Thank you.
So first of all, thank you. Thank you.
I will say on my role on the ACS CAN board, we use your data all
the time to do advocacy on the Hill, and it's incredibly important.
So what I want to ask, and I know you kind of skirted around this, and I know
Bill's there, but don't look at him. Don't look at Bill. Okay?
It's not rocket science, right, what you've shown and the impact of the Affordable
Care Act, et cetera. Can you just share with us what your thoughts are in terms of
the predictions of what's going to happen with the rollbacks of Medicaid
and the rollbacks of the support for the Affordable Care Act?
Yeah, that's a great question. I think we
have been making progress, but there would be, as I
said...
On the subsidy alone, in 2025, there
were 20
million
individuals who use subsidies. Okay, 20 million.
That's a lot. And I'm sure
about one in six, I believe,
I
don't remember exactly, but-A substantial
proportion of them could not buy insurance.
That would be in millions. And those who bought, I
don't know for how
long they can sustain it.
If you don't have insurance in this
country, you are by your own. Okay?
So there would be the progress that we have made in the
last 10 years, they probably reverse that.
So that's not really a rocket scientist to find out that.
But the data will speak in a few years. Will, yeah.
And this is really a real-world experiment.
This is really, yeah. That's what researchers do.
But it is unfortunate.
Any questions?
Over here.
Good afternoon again. Admiration all around.
What a privilege to hear you speak, and obviously one of those that has used your
data a lot and had the privilege of publishing with you.
Just
given everything that you have seen throughout time and all of the data
that you have access to,
I am curious, from your purview, what are some questions that we are
not asking? What is
a piece of work that we are not yet doing in the field that based on
the data that you see, we should be doing, or a question that we
should be asking that we are not?
Oh, yeah.
So
I think the
data still, it is
publicly available data.
The
data is limited to some extent. If we were, for example, to have to
argument the data with more clinical genetic data,
probably we can do more.
But I think the question is still there are, for example, now the
rural disparity is a big question.
We just published
a paper led by Farad and Jenny Zi showing
this crossover in
disparity between rural and urban, and now it is widening.
Okay.
That data exists, but we
are not just paying attention to the data. That's important.
The current administration is interested in rural
disparity. So there would be a lot of research questions that can
be asked to inform public policy.
But
it's a very broad question. But I do believe
that still the data that we are having in the
cancer registries have been limited by, especially
there is a lag
in time. For example, if you look at treatment data, treatment
changes, but the most recent data that we have on treatment,
even it is not complete, okay, it is four, five years
behind. And, yeah. So
I'm sure there is Chris also there, okay, he may
have some questions. Yeah.
Any other questions?
You can run down.
Okay. Thank you.